friday afternoon it's a sunny and warm
day in vancouver
and uh but you know it's interesting
day 59 it is another challenge
time flies when you're having fun when
you're having fun two-thirds of the way
through i have some comments about what
i have noticed
but i'd like to begin by asking you uh
what have you known as galena now you
presumably you've been going at it
heavier in your french uh
i think uh i'm getting more familiar
with the language even with grammar
um i have a good book
grammar book so sometimes i just uh look
through
to have a general understanding about
the language and
and i noticed also that when you have
uh when you have a goal when you have a
specific time you're more motivated so
it really motivates me to good to stay
on track right
okay so you've noticed more motivation
mark
um
yeah for sure it was good for me to have
a challenge like this to sort of
force myself to make a point of
spending time on on uh
my language i i did a talent and i ended
up doing it from scratch because i had
never really done much italian on link
um
i'm really not a beginner in italian so
but but even having said that i am
surprised at how uh
much i understand now and not
necessarily
if people are speaking you know 100
percent naturally in it at the
native speed or you know like if they're
speaking to each other they're speaking
very quickly
sometimes that can be harder to pick up
but when i read uh
news articles i mean yeah there's most
there's not that many words that i don't
that i can't figure out at any rate and
probably because i've had italian done
some italian before i mean i lived there
for six months
and i studied quite a bit of french
and a lot of words are similar to
english for all those reasons but even
still
i guess i'm surprised at uh how much i
understand when i
that's quite a
an encouraging feeling when you sort of
suddenly get that feeling that you
understand more yeah exactly yeah
exactly yeah i would say with my korean
um
because i've moved on to very difficult
content now which is this uh
podcast about books and so forth it's
it's very difficult it's it's like
you know it's like a
jigsaw puzzle and more and more of it
seems to
kind of become clear but i'm still
struggling but i know that it's it's
it's that slow i almost see it as i
think in a video i said it was like this
the water torture but it is it's like
erosion it's like i just know from
experience that this letting it all wash
over me gradually through erosion
certain forms are gonna you know stand
out more and and so it's just a gradual
process
um one thing i noticed is not in korean
but in russian
is how
it always amazes me how certain things
take a long time to stick
for example
in russia when you talk about
you know canadians
or chinese as in people
you know it's um
cannot say
right or kit
okay
and i've always had trouble with that
because for whatever reason it's always
menoga something so
right so i always even though i know
theoretically that that it should be
entitled i'm just talking about i'm not
mold i'm just saying chinese people
and and so i've always had trouble
end up saying
for those of us that don't understand
any of the russian could you explain
that it's just chinese okay and so i
kept on using the wrong
the wrong ending
and for some reason i'm listening to
this thing on russian and they're
talking about the
rumbles and the nets there and they're
talking about eyewitnesses
yeah and that it clicked
it just suddenly clicked and it just
suddenly realized and now i will have no
trouble saying
and cannots and so forth so it's just
that
things take time and you never know when
they're gonna click it
and so you just have to continue it's
like the water torture it just keeps
coming at you and slowly and and you
know this stuff has started to
accumulate in your brain but you can't
yet make use of it and all of a sudden
you will and i have that experience a
lot of time and that's why
you know i say 90 days i don't know what
i'm going to achieve in 90 days but i'm
putting a lot of stuff in there that
will be good for me even beyond the 90
days and that's why i think this sort of
three months fluency
is is i just don't believe in it because
you'll do some stuff in three months and
a lot of what you learn in three months
in fact won't come out until later on so
you won't have that three months to
fluency that's just not going to happen
so
yeah so that was a bit of a revelation
for me by the way speaking of three
months to fluency someone asked me to
review benny's book right
so i should say i'm not going to review
benny's book
because i don't believe in the title of
the book is anyone can achieve fluency
in three months in any language i don't
believe that not for a minute
however let me just finish however
that's not to say that it isn't a
worthwhile book
because the big thing is motivation
and benny certainly knows a lot of
things about language learning that we
know maybe and that a lot of people
don't know
and he is very motivating so it may very
well be a very useful book
to motivate people but because i don't
believe in the concept of three months
of fluency i'm not going to read the
book just in order to write a negative
you know book review it may be though
that he doesn't in fact say that in the
book it could be it says cover i know
but you don't know what it says in the
book i'm just saying i'm not
possible
sometimes people say i have a title and
then in the book proceed to
explain why in fact that's not the case
like when i used to sell encyclopedias
and you've heard my encyclopedia i
haven't maybe refreshed my memory well
when i was 17 i used to sell
encyclopedias door-to-door encyclopedia
britannica and the line we were given we
had to say as if you managed to get your
foot in the door that they let you in
which is
a very small percentage mostly it's beat
it
but
the line was
if i if you could get a full set of
encyclopedia britannica 24 volumes for
free would you be interested
and so here's this parent whatever oh
yes
okay let me come here and explain so
then i go through my whole spiel and we
had to for example we had to pick up the
book by one page and see how you know
strong the paper is i think you can do
that to any book but anyway this was the
thing running through the whole thing
and then i would say now of course you
must understand we can't give you the
encyclopedia for free
however for less than you spend on
cigarettes
but so yeah maybe benny that's his line
who knows what was the response when you
did they were i wasn't kicked out
immediately
but let's say their interest level
dropped
so no to be fair to benny i am sure that
it has a lot of motivating stuff in it
and a lot of very practical stuff about
how to learn away from the classroom
so to that extent uh you know i'm sure
people should certainly give given a
look from my point of view but uh
i just feel as i say 90 days to
concentrate to get a lot of stuff in you
some of which is going to work for you
in that 90-day period and some of it is
just going to come back to you and work
for you later on
so therefore one should never be
discouraged that you know i've been
doing it for
you know 60 days and i haven't mastered
the language what's wrong with me no no
if you keep doing it you will get better
and there will be these eureka moments
like you were saying where all of a
sudden you feel you understand so much
of the italian
or the french yeah and for sure we are
going to keep learning our languages
after
the 90s
exactly
okay
any other comments
i don't think so okay